tonight we're also learning more we're
learning more about the bizarre 2018 gun
incident surrounding hunter biden
and his late brother's widow haley
involving a firearm that was reportedly
tossed behind a wilmington delaware
grocery store because according to the
new york post texts from hunter biden
himself
suggest that the secret service was
involved in the incident
despite contrary claims from the agency
quote she stole the gun out of my trunk
lock box and threw it in a garbage can
filled to the top at jansen's
then told me it was my problem to deal
with end quote
hunter wrote according to messages
obtained by the new york post
hunter then continued quote then when
the police the fbi and the secret
service came on the scene
she said she took it from me because she
was scared i would harm myself
due to my drug and alcohol problem and
our volatile i don't volatile
relationship
end quote there's even more because
according to politico a new documents
obtained by the federalist
hunter may have lied on his federal form
4473
about his past drug use when he answered
no
to question 11e about drug and substance
abuse
and today senators grassley and johnson
have sent letters to the secret service
the fbi
and the atf demanding answers about the
incident
we've reached out to hunter biden's
lawyer for comment but have yet to hear
anything back
the secret service has denied the agency
was involved in the gun store
incident joining me now for reaction
house minority whip steve scalise along
with fox news
contributor charlie hurt congressman
i'll go to you first uh this is just
contributing to the growing perception
in america
that there are two sets of rules for the
bow tie wearing elites
um and for everyone else i mean this
can't possibly be received well we're
reading hunter biden's
own text it's not like we made this up
yeah dan there there are a number of
really serious concerns
that are raised when you read that
political article frankly it mentions
multiple potential violations of federal
law
not the least of which as you mentioned
if he
lied about drug use on the federal forum
but also just
throwing a gun in the trash can if you
read the article about some of the
conversations he had with police
it almost sounds like he was getting
tested with police because they were
asking him basic questions
uh he there was slurs that were made
about
people here from mexico i mean a lot of
things in that police report
that are very alarming but again you've
got president biden right now talking
about
passing more gun control making it
harder for law-abiding citizens to get a
gun
and yet here you have a case of his son
who
from all appearances broke multiple laws
and
gets off scot-free and like you said
what does the secret service even
have to do with this joe biden wasn't
vice president he didn't even have
secret service protection
at the time and yet the secret service
went and tried to pull
the gun records from the gun store
luckily the gun owner didn't
give those records over to him but again
what are they doing trying to
get those records a lot of serious
questions that ought to be raised but we
shouldn't be passing gun control to make
it harder
for law-abiding citizens stop people who
break the law
uh from getting away with it scot-free
yeah i mean the the irony here is so
thick
uh it's impossible to ignore charlie and
and one other component to this
you know charlie if this was a story
forget about don junior this was a story
about
don jr's cousin's friend's neighbor and
don had a hot dog at his house 30 years
ago
this would be a front page story
everywhere all over the cosmos
and yet because it's a story about
hunter biden it'll receive a light touch
everywhere
no the it's a the massive cover-up for
the bidens is
something that we've never witnessed
before in in modern
uh american politics it's just appalling
and
by the way i know a lot of gun owners
all three of us we all know
lots of gun owners i don't know anybody
who would
first of all throw a a weapon away
in a trash can in a a in a high
trafficked
area like that uh in the first place in
the second place
i don't know anybody who would ever lie
on one of those forms
uh and the fact that you have you know a
clear questions about whether
hunter biden did lie on those forms
raises all kinds of very important
questions
that that obviously need to be answered
um but but
of course the biggest the most appalling
part of all of it is the fact
that here we are at a time where as you
point out uh
joe biden and democrats are talking
unlike they've talked ever before
about going after law abiding gun owners
and making it harder for law abiding gun
owners who would never do
any of these things to prevent them
and to curtail their abilities to
protect themselves protect their
families to protect their neighbors
but this is just the way that apparently
the way the bidens roll
and it's it's disgusting and and we have
to get to the bottom of it and i think a
big reason why politicians often do this
sort of thing
they they uh go for the shiny object and
try to
come up with new rules that they want to
go after is because it's an admission
that they have failed to enforce all of
the laws that are currently on the books
and that's usually how bad things wind
up happening
yeah good point charlie congressman is
there any appetite whatsoever
on the hill to investigate this family
anymore i mean
how much is this guy going to get away
with talking about hunter
i mean the accusations here are are the
stuff of almost
legend payoffs from russian oligarchs i
mean
this is the kind of stuff again if it
involved anyone even close to the trump
orbit
it would be a cosmic scandal from like
an avengers movie is there any appetite
to investigate here
yeah dan and you can see there's already
requests being made for this to be
investigated
i'm waiting for the biden justice
department to investigate
but again if you replaced the words
biden
with trump and then you read that
article the political article that
really goes into detail about the police
report
alarming questions all throughout if
that was trump instead of biden
every newspaper in the country would be
all over it would be the lead story
on all of the mainstream media outlets
and yet crickets like everything else
but people are watching this
it's like the double standard you see
with so many of these democrat officials
who break the rules they tell you to
live by one set of rules they're living
by another
they're trying to take away your
freedoms when they're not even complying
they're trying to take away our gun
rights as we speak in washington and the
president of the united states himself
is talking about
going nuclear and blowing up the
filibuster in the senate to get gun
control
and make it harder for you to get a gun
and yet his own son looks like
violated multiple laws why don't you
force the laws that are on the books
instead of going after people
who aren't breaking the laws like hurt
said
yeah well congressman thanks please
follow up on that i mean really america
needs accountability here so we really
appreciate it charlie
congressman thanks a lot absolutely
coming up